James O'Keefe in one of I got to say one
of his best exposes ever apparently he
went on a date with a guy and he went it
was like a Clark Kent thing he put on
glasses and then he starts asking this
guy all these stuff about what's going
on in the White House this is an
executive uh what is an employee in the
executive office of the White House in
cyber security who explains they want to
replace Kamal Hara Kam Harris they don't
know how to do it they know Joe Biden's
in mental Decline and they're stuck
there's a lot more that came out in this
report but the best is probably when
James O'Keefe takes his glasses off and
says why are you having a meeting with
James O'Keefe if you're working in cyber
security and the guy's just like
dumbfounded I love it it's like you
didn't know that was James cuz he was
wearing glasses and the guy's like oh
yeah I've heard of you oh wow that's an
amazing story